[Música]
después de seis semanas de asedio por
parte de sus tropas rusia anunció la
toma de la ciudad de mariupol el segundo
puerto de importancia para ucrania y
punto estratégico en el mar de azov así
lo indicó el ministro de defensa de la
federación de rusia serguéi shoigú y el
presidente vladimir putin
en las fuerzas armadas de la federación
rusa y las milicias de las repúblicas
populares de donges han liberado
mariupol los remanentes de las
formaciones nacionalistas se han
refugiado en la zona industrial de la
planta de azov tal en cuanto a hoy toda
mariupol está bajo control del ejército
ruso de la milicia de la república
popular de donges y el territorio de la
planta de azov tal con los remanentes de
los nacionalistas y los mercenarios
extranjeros está bloqueado de forma
segura se decide dentro
considero que el asalto propuesto a la
zona industrial es innecesaria y ordenó
cancelarlo este es un caso que debemos
evaluar quiero decir nosotros siempre
debemos evaluar pero en este caso aún
más sobre preservar las vidas y la salud
de nuestros soldados y oficiales no hay
necesidad de escalar en esas catacumbas
y arrastrarse bajo esas instalaciones
industriales bloqueen esta área
industrial para que ni una mosca pueda
pasar
del otro lado los defensores ucranianos
aseguran que la ciudad está
prácticamente en ruinas sus habitantes
han escapado o muerto indicaron que pese
a esto mariupol sigue siendo ucraniana
yo sé que han capturado la mayor parte
de mariupol hace mucho tiempo somos muy
conscientes de eso pero hay una parte de
nuestra ciudad donde permanecen nuestros
militares y se quedarán allí por ahora
solos
y es que cerca de 2.000 soldados
ucranianos mercenarios y combatientes
del batallón díaz op resisten los
ataques en la enorme zona industrial de
la planta de as hostal en donde también
hay unos 1000 civiles que están
resguardando si allí resistiendo los
ataques rusos así lo destacó el alcalde
de mariupol escuchemos mariupol fue es y
sigue siendo ucrania hoy porque hoy
nuestros valientes guerreros nuestros
héroes están defendiendo nuestra ciudad
tanto como es posible entonces no
importa que declaraciones se hagan la
ciudad es y será ucraniana bueno la
pregunta que queda entonces es cayó o no
cayó la ciudad de mariupol ha sido
liberada o no por parte de las tropas
rusas estamos ante otro episodio de
guerra de información entre rusia y
ucrania de ser comprobada entonces la
caída de esta ciudad que significa para
rusia que se muestra ahora como
victoriosa con este logro y que
representaría entonces para ucrania en
los términos de la guerra también vale
la pena destacar otros hechos que
tuvieron lugar a lo largo de esta semana
por ese cuantioso apoyo monetario que el
presidente de eeuu joe biden anunció
para darle a ucrania también la visita a
kiev del presidente del gobierno español
pedro sánchez que anunció también la
entrega de ayudas militares la prueba
del lanzamiento de un misil de alcance
intercontinental por parte de rusia que
fue aprovechada por el presidente
vladimir putin para mostrar músculo
militar y también para amenazar a
algunos países de la comunidad
internacional que busca entonces el
presidente ruso con estas pruebas
militares y también es y ponta
importante analizar esos 5 millones de
migrantes ucranianos cuya mayoría se
están concentrando en los países vecinos
como por ejemplo en polonia hungría y
moldavia hoy en el debate de france 24
analizamos los hechos más recientes
relacionados con la guerra en ucrania y
para analizar este tema hemos invitado a
la doctora beata
boina así lo pronunció bien en polaco
internacionalista y profesora de
relaciones internacionales en el tec de
monterrey en méxico la doctora boina
también fue embajadora de polonia ante
el gobierno de méxico y de los países
centroamericanos entre los años 2014 y
2018 también desde san juan de puerto
rico se conecta el doctor lajos szaszdi
ahora pronunció en húngaro analista de
relaciones internacionales y estudios
estratégicos de fuerzas terrestres
navales aéreas y espaciales rusas es
también profesor adjunto de la
universidad interamericana de la isla de
puerto rico ustedes nuestros
televidentes también pueden participar
en este debate con todos los comentarios
y preguntas que quieran hacer sobre este
tema lo pueden hacer a través de las
redes sociales en facebook en instagram
y en twitter estamos como france24 guión
bajo s arroba santi logo que es mi
cuenta personal les recuerdo que nuestra
etiqueta es numeral el debate efe 24
esperamos por supuesto todos sus
comentarios y sus preguntas a través de
las redes sociales para que ustedes
también participen en este en este
debate comenzó entonces preguntándole a
la doctora bovina en mexico por esta
supuesta caída de mariupol tal parece
que se está dando allí otra
guerra informática o guerra a nivel
informativa entre ucrania y rusia rusia
afirma que la ciudad ya fue liberada por
las tropas rusas por lo menos así lo dan
a conocer desde el punto de vista ruso
pero desde el punto de visto craneano ya
lo decíamos han dicho que la ciudad
sigue en manos ucranianas
pues la verdad es que la ciudad de mayo
paul después de muchos días de asedio y
de bombardeos
pues está mayoritariamente controlada
por los rusos eso sí es un hecho pero
por otra parte también es un hecho que
hay un grupo de ucranianos tantos
soldados como civiles que están
resguardados justamente en la fábrica de
esas hostal desde donde pues han andado
batalla a las fuerzas armadas rusas que
no han podido ocupar básicamente esta
fábrica con ese grupo de más de 2.000
soldados ucranianos y arise de eso pues
han decidido se puede decir la calles de
la parte rusa pues declarar una especie
de victoria pero dejando aparte este
este lugar y con la decisión de putin
pues decidiendo básicamente que hay que
cortar todas las vías de comunicación
todas las vías de imposible abasto y de
lo que se trata fundamentalmente es de
de sacar a los que están en
asustar en la fábrica a sus tal pues
bajo bajo fuerza de hambre y falta de
agua y falta de medicinas o sea
básicamente condenarles a una muerte
lenta
porque seguramente no se van a rendir
entonces en ese sentido yo diría que son
obviamente la narrativa rusa tiene como
objetivo demostrar que si han logrado el
objetivo de conquistar de ocupar
mariupol lo presentan como una
liberación de la ciudad lo cual pues es
absolutamente mentira tomando en
consideración que la ciudad es una
ciudad ucraniana que fue invadida por
rusia igual que el territorio ucraniano
fue invadido por rusa o rusia y además
era una ciudad pues que funcionaba muy
bien hoy en día es una ciudad
completamente destruida 90 por ciento de
la infraestructura civil de la
estructura de la ciudad pues está ésta
está completamente destruida y los
ciudadanos que han vivido ahí más de 400
mil personas
han logrado salir de esta ciudad pero
muchos se quedan ahí se calcula como
civiles que están ahí en mariupol
doctors así su opinión sobre este tema
cayó o no cayó fue liberado no fue
liberada la ciudad de mariupol a manos
de las tropas rusas cuál es la
perspectiva que usted tiene sobre este
tema y por qué las tropas rusas están
tal parece que enseñadas con esta ciudad
por qué es tan importante para el
ejército ruso
conquistar esta ciudad sí claro bueno lo
primero es que el liberado sería la
retórica de moscú y no podría ser jamás
liberada por moscú porque hemos coge el
invasor es el agresor sólo sería
liberada si ucrania logra su fuerza
armada levantar el cerco y la ocupación
rusa de la parte que controla que
aparentemente es la mayor parte de las
ruinas de mariupol
para él
han logrado conquistarlo no los rusos
bueno sabemos que en esos tal este gran
conglomerado industrial de acero que
tiene bunkers varios niveles bajo tierra
porque parece que tenía bunkers contrato
contra guerra nuclear de tiempos de la
unión soviética y pues están como mil
combatientes ucranianos y hay también
refugiados civiles pero se me ocurre
algo de eso no se habla no sería caso
que en algunas partes de la ciudad pues
es una ciudad grande y habrían
combatientes en unidades guerrilleras y
ucranianos que podrían incluso estar
moviéndose a través de las cloacas por
ejemplo para salir a llevar a cabo en
buscadas a la superficie y llevar a cabo
emboscadas esta es mi especulación pero
no necesariamente no lo sabemos yo no lo
sé pero podría ser que haya algunos
otros pocos grupos estaríamos hablando
unidades de 7 a 10 hombres
o menos incluso de guerrilleros soldados
ucranianos milicianos ucranianos que
estarían usando los escombros para
llevar a cabo emboscadas entonces hay
una cosa que hay que tomar en cuenta
ella se decía hace unos días que
antes de la llamada rendición de mil
infantes de marina ucranianos que es lo
que los rusos decían que las tropas
rusas había un alto número que estaba
siendo
comprometida para rodear o para llevar a
cabo el ataque contra esos tal no era el
ataque final o sea o la conquista si
quieres de mariupol se estaba atando un
alto número de tropas que no las usaban
en otros frentes entonces eso de por sí
tiene valor para las fuerzas armadas
ucranianas porque les entretiene en esta
guerra él aclaró y más y putin dice que
no la tomen por asalto porque sería muy
costoso podemos asumir que habría
trampas explosivas vienen los rusos y
hacen volar ciertos túneles los
ucranianos los defensores
para destruir ese ataque entonces pues
no no no lo han sometido podrían quizás
incluso hasta llevarse a cabo ataques
desde la fábrica si hay varios niveles y
si hay túneles conectados al sistema de
desagüe de la ciudad
así que por qué es tan importante para
acabar bueno porque así podrían decir y
celebrar el 9 de mayo que es lo que
quiere vladimir putin en su famoso
desfile de la victoria de europa 2
contra alemania de hitler that sí pues
con su parada de tanques de moscú que
han logrado sus objetivos en la guerra
de ucrania realmente su objetivo era
tragarse todo el país no lo logró
entonces decir bueno captura mariupol y
ya hemos capturado el 10 lugar la costa
del mar de azov tienen a crimea gerzón y
bueno decir que han logrado pero ya los
expertos occidentales y a cabo están
diciendo que la batalla el donbass como
le ha llamado el presidente hacia les
puede durar meses y será una guerra
así que vamos a abrir para consentirse
doctor se dice me adelantó a usted a mi
siguiente pregunta que le va a hacer a
la doctora boina y era precisamente esa
necesidad que tiene rusia de mostrar
resultados esa necesidad de mostrar
victorias en esta guerra que se está
extendiendo más de lo que moscú kiev
bruselas y washington estaban esperando
que iba a durar será este entonces ese
primer trofeo digámoslo así como lo
puede llamar moscú y como lo decía el
doctor saudí para mostrar el día de 9 de
mayo el día de la victoria para poder
calmar un poco los ánimos entre la
sociedad rusa que análisis puede hacer
usted
pues no cabe duda que mariupol en este
sentido si es un primer trofeo y putin
lo puede presentar de esta forma aunque
en el terreno no necesariamente es que
toda la ciudad está ocupada y dominada
por los rusos esta ciudad tiene también
otro significado en un significado
estratégico un relevantísimo es un
puerto es un puerto que da al mar de
azov entonces la ocupación de esta
ciudad pues de alguna forma se puede
decir debilita a ucrania y la priva en
caso de que rusia se quede con ese
territorio digamos por más tiempo la
priva de un acceso al mar del cual
salían básicamente los barcos ucranianos
pues principalmente con con cereales que
exportaban con trigo con cebada con
girasol que exportaban a diferentes
partes del mundo entonces hay un
significado económico que estratégico de
este puerto para ucrania es una pérdida
importante para el país por otra parte
éste mariupol es también una ciudad que
conecta a ucrania oriental con ucrania
del sur y con primera y en ese sentido
hay que hay que tener en consideración
que precisamente ese de los rusos de
ocupar mariupol estaba relacionado con
la necesidad de ocupar una ciudad que es
una ciudad del tránsito y de conexión
entre las dos partes de ucrania que
rusia quiere ocupar es la parte del sur
que ya está parcialmente ocupada en
crimea y está parcialmente ocupada
también la ciudad más grande otra ciudad
más grande de esta elección que es
gerson donde además los rusos quieren
realizar un referéndum precisamente para
que esa ciudad y toda esa región de
gerson declara su independencia
repitiendo un poco el esquema de lugares
y dones entonces esa parte del sur
conectando la con la franja en ucrania
oriental donde se encuentran las dos
repúblicas declaradas independientes y
reconocidas independientes por rusia
nunca en sidón es entonces ese es el
significado pleno de mariupol a lo cual
se estima suma también esa posibilidad
de liberar las fuerzas armadas rusas
como ya ya lo han mencionado a mi cola
muy colega húngaro este liberar las
fuerzas armadas rusas para pasarlas
y dirigirla es precisamente al frente
oriental o sea al donbass precisamente
para allí puedes realizar toda una serie
de operaciones en un frente que es
larguísimo de 480 kilómetros con muchas
ciudades y la verdad es que
posibilidades de ocupación difíciles
como lo hemos visto en otras partes de
ucrania también además que acceder un
poco más al sur de mariupol le
permitiría a las tropas rusas conectar
ya los territorios ganados en el norte
de crimea y le permitiría a rusia estar
conectada de forma terrestre con la
península de crimea y no a través del
estrecho de kerch y ya permitiría
digamos unificar por tierra ese
territorio a la federación de rusia dr
saudí pasó a preguntarle en línea por lo
que usted nos está comentando de esa
necesidad de rusia de mostrar logros
para esa fecha importante para la
federación de rusia que es el día de la
victoria el día de la victoria del
ejército rojo rojo sobre los nazis el
presidente putin está bajo mucha presión
al interior del país porque ya sabemos
las consecuencias que ha tenido a nivel
internacional las sanciones y la presión
que ay pero al interior de rusia como
está el presidente putin
bueno podríamos decir que aunque hay un
estado represivo para que la gente no
exprese libremente en público sus
opiniones en contra de la guerra porque
los arrestan los detienen o con el caso
del editor en jefe de 'nóvaya gazeta'
que bueno pues el que ganó el premio
nobel él ha cerrado el periódico porque
podrían someterse sus periodistas a 15
años de la cárcel en la cárcel de
prisión por decidir cómo dicen fake news
noticia falsa que es decir la verdad de
que hay una guerra en ucrania y que no
les está yendo bien entonces por un lado
ahí yo diría una olla de presión es
estar en mi opinión a pesar que se
podría decir que ha habido muchos rusos
que han apoyado a putin pero por su
imperialismo etcétera la gran rusia pero
ahora las sanciones están empezando a
morder
no hay creo que ciertos productos de los
supermercados los precios se están
disparando
por el corte digamos que de las
relaciones rusas con el comercio
internacional el hecho que no pueden
disponer de sus reservas en el
extranjero no le divisa fuerte de oro la
mitad de todas sus reservas creo que
estaba en bancos del grupo de los siete
vamos a decir en general y más suiza
etcétera
está también el descontento por las
pérdidas de las vidas de conscriptos de
jóvenes reclutados de 18 años 1920 años
que se suponía que no estuvieran en una
guerra pues en ucrania
pero los han estado usando en la línea
de frente y eso incluye el crucero
moskvá moscú que parece que ha habido
marineros que han sido conscriptos han
desaparecido moscú incluso pues no ha
reconocido el número total de muertos en
el crucero al hundirse y al ser atacado
por los dos misiles neptuno ucranianos
entonces hay protestas de eso así que
podemos decir descontento
y otra cosa parece que hay miembros de
la fsb de lo que yo llamo el aparato de
seguridad inteligencia rusia que en mi
opinión es la élite que manda y putin
era su primos interpares el que ellos
eligieron para gobernar pero que ahora
putin parece que es como mini stalin un
mini hitler que se ha rodeado se ha
aislado
rodear a una base de gente
incondicional y entonces pues hay
descontento entre ellos y los generales
destituidos el que no sé si llegan a
mente por no haber conquistado ucrania o
haberle mentido etcétera o sea que
podríamos decir que incluso en su grupo
de la fsb hay descontento y lo último
dos cosas que llaman la atención y que
me recuerdan de métodos de la n kv de
debería y de stalin ha aparecido el
vicepresidente de gazprom bank el banco
de gazprom ya saben el gigante joya de
la corona rusa no monopolio estatal de
gas natural hace bueno asesinado
presuntamente por disparos su mujer
hembra
y su actual mujer la que era su actual
mujer y su niña de 13 años los tres
asesinados en moscú en su piso de lujo y
hoy salió la noticia que otro de esos el
vicepresidente de la mesa directiva de
novatech que creo que era pues la mayor
si no me equivoco empresa de gas natural
privada de rusia pero que hacía el juego
claro los intereses de moscú ha
aparecido ahorcado en cataluña la costa
brava en su residencia de lujo sin su
esposa y su hija de 18 años hemos
asesinadas a machetazos o hachazo social
así que que sería que estas personas
estaban opuestas al régimen y ahora
putin está desesperado asesinando para
que nadie pues se elector de en contra
entre a pregunta
punto importante doctor de paso
preguntarle a doctora boina en mexico
por otro de los actores importantes de
este rompecabezas de la guerra de
ucrania y estados unidos esta semana
anunció más sanciones contra
más sanciones económicas para rusia y
también anunció una ayuda económica de
japón no así para el gobierno ucraniano
para seguir haciendo frente a la
situación que se está viviendo allí por
la invasión de rusia reclaman más
presencia de eeuu eeuu que análisis
puede hacer usted doctora boina de los
hechos recientes se mantiene muy al
margen se esperaba que eeuu se
involucrará más en este conflicto o sabe
claramente contra qué enemigo es el que
se está enfrentando que es vladimir
putin
bueno si eeuu es el país que más ayuda
de carácter militar
humanitario y económico ha proporcionado
a ucrania es hasta ahora y comparamos a
todos los países que forman parte de la
llamada coalición del occidente a los
que son miembros de la unión europea de
la alianza atlántica algunos países más
en total como una treintena de países
los eeuu han
proporcionado a ucrania en este contexto
más o menos casi 8 mil millones de
dólares
de los 15.000 millones que han
proporcionado todos los países del
occidente
sin contar aquí el apoyo de las
organizaciones internacionales en ese
sentido el anuncio del presidente vaivén
de que pues va a proveer nuevamente 800
millones de dólares pues se suma se
puede decir a esa política de realmente
desembolsar bastante para que las
necesidades de ucrania las necesidades
relacionadas con la guerra se cubra
y en cuanto a eso yo creo que no hay
ninguna duda de que si hay un compromiso
pues real de los eeuu para apoyar a
ucrania un compromiso que también
obviamente tienen otros países de la
coalición del occidente a otros países
la unión europa de la alianza atlántica
pero sí destacaría yo ese punto y ese
punto salió a raíz de una investigación
que han publicado justamente esta semana
los investigadores alemanes de que el
institut
pérez subrayando revelando esa
información
ahora bien obviamente también hay
límites del apoyo de los eeuu los eeuu
como el principal país de la alianza
atlántica
pues ha declarado con claridad que no va
a haber soldados estadounidenses en el
territorio de ucrania y tampoco va a
haber involucramiento de la alianza
atlántica o involucramiento de los
soldados bajo paraguas de la alianza
atlántica en el territorio de ucrania
para no escalar la que el conflicto a
una guerra mayor y finalmente tampoco va
a haber armas pesadas ahora está
cambiando un poco de esa retórica de los
eeuu
las declaraciones han aparecido de esta
semana también que van a empezar los
envíos de armas más pesadas sobre todo
relacionadas con la artillería
y sin armas y si desde hace tiempo está
solicitando precisamente sin embargo el
presidente de ucrania volodymyr selenski
sigue pidiendo más ayuda a la comunidad
internacional dice que no es suficiente
en lo que han recibido hasta ahora
debido a la escalada que empezó
precisamente rusia a lo largo de los
últimos días también para destacar
doctora boina la visita allí a kiev del
presidente del gobierno español pedro
sánchez prácticamente estuvo allí unas
horas después de un largo viaje desde la
frontera con polonia y también anunció
ayuda por parte del gobierno español una
porción de ayuda militar con para el
ejército ucraniano que podemos decir de
esta presencia española allí que se
puede decir de la parte de colaboración
que está haciendo la unión europea y le
hago la misma pregunta al doctor salt y
para hacer el análisis entre los dos
mira yo creo que el tema de la visita
del primer ministro sánchez
en ucrania pues es que se suma ya varias
visitas que se han realizado de parte de
los líderes de europa occidental de la
unión europa de la alianza atlántica en
el contexto de ucrania en kiev y las
reuniones que han tenido precisamente
con el presidente de leyes que es un
símbolo muy importante de que hay apoyo
de los países de la unión europea y de
los países de la alianza atlántica a los
esfuerzos de ucrania a la lucha de
ucrania en esta en esta guerra contra
contra la invasión rusa y tiene un yo
creo que si el significado simbólico
pero también es un significado pues real
en forma de los compromisos a través de
declaraciones muy concretas sobre cuánto
dinero cuánto ayuda militar se va a
destinar a ucrania y eso sí es relevante
y eso sí cuenta muchísimo en este
sentido también ha sido muy importante
el regreso de varias embajadas de los
países occidentales aquí es recordemos
que antes de iniciar la guerra muchas
embajadas prácticamente todas se fueron
de kiev
se alojaron en el dif y después incluso
se salieron totalmente de ucrania hoy ya
tenemos la situación del regreso de esas
embajadas y lo cual nos refleja con
claridad de que ucrania pues ha ganado
la batalla de quien básicamente y con lo
que se enfrenta hoy en día es con esa
nueva fase de la uar guerra que
constituye básicamente en ganar la
batalla de donbass vamos a ver como como
cómo va a ir este este proceso pero no
cabe duda que este tipo de visitas si
tienen su relevancia hay visitas que se
han hecho y hay visitas sigue a la parte
ucraniana dicho que no se pueden hacer
es el caso del presidente de alemania
cuya visita pues está a punto de
realizarse fue rechazada y rechazada
porque el presidente está en mayo
fue uno de los que avaló
el north stream que es este gasoducto
que va a conectar a rusia con alemania o
que conecta rusia con alemania pero que
nunca fue puesto en marcha debido al
conflicto que se está viviendo en este
momento ya otras discrepancias
internacionales doctor salt y si tiene
algo que añadir de este tema de la unión
europea adelante le doy espacio para que
haga una un comentario al respecto y
también quiero preguntarle por un tema
que yo sé que usted nos va a dar muchos
datos y es el tema de esa prueba de ese
misil que hizo rusia también esta semana
que también puso a temblar al mundo
entero sino que bueno es muy importante
el hecho de que se está movilizando al
hablar de la unión europea el proceso de
admisión de ucrania a la unión europea
que se ha estado diciendo hasta ahora
que ucrania no va entrar en la otan pero
básicamente como vio las cosas y que con
todo el apoyo armamento que le están
dando ucrania pues la otan es como que
si ucrania ya es miembro de la otan y
está combatiendo en nombre de la otan
pero si no tan oficialmente estar
combatiendo y los rusos putin
aparentemente considera que pues ya hay
realmente una guerra entre los y rusia
pero en suelo ucraniano entonces y bueno
está el tema de la expansión de la unión
europea incluyendo ucrania está el tema
de la otan de la futura aparente
integración de finlandia y de suecia ya
que putin que ha estado amenazando a
estos países escandinavos neutrales que
no sean miembros pero claro con su
destrucción y genocidios y crímenes de
guerra en ucrania pues quien no va a
intentar buscar la protección colectiva
de la otan que probablemente en mi
especulación si después de la revolución
naranja del 2004 2005 cuando ya se había
que putin claramente quería tragarse
ucrania con yanukóvich
y siendo el presidente saliente leonid
kuchmá amigo de putin pues ahí debieron
de haber invitado a ucrania a la otan no
lo hicieron y si hubiera sido él optan
probablemente putin o se hubiera
atrevido a atacar a ucrania preso él
hubiera no existe como de diario
entonces
el tema de la política alemana el cambio
precisamente por esto de que steinmeier
pues no se le ha permitido entrar pero
ha habido una
fórmula se ha reformulado la política
alemana hacia rusia y van a depender
menos de gas de petróleo se va a haber
un cambio reconocen su error de haber
dependido tanto de los hidrocarburos
rusos y van a gastar más en armamento
como ya saben y además van a dedicar
mayor esfuerzo militar aparentemente
para la protección de los países ricos
de lituania letonia estonia
finalmente armamentos pesados bueno eeuu
va a dar 72 cañones de artillería
autopropulsada de 155 milímetros m 109 a
6 paladín paladín es 144 mil proyectiles
pueden haber proyectiles inteligentes de
estos que son guiados por satélite o por
la serviría terminal para impactar con
un solo tiro de esos obuses un tanque
enemigos como los proyectiles copperhead
que ya existen en los años 80 entonces
es casas de combate
parece no se ha confirmado creo todavía
que bulgaria va a proporcionar bersani
nueves porque van los americanos a
venderle 8 cazas f-16 como los que tiene
por ejemplo volviendo
se me acaba el tiempo ya estoy bastante
final del programa y quería preguntarle
para que nos diera datos de ese misil
que hizo pruebas en rusia que voló desde
el noroeste del país hasta la península
de kamtchatka y con el que vladimir
putin aprovechó para amenazar a los
países alrededor del mundo diciendo que
las naciones pensarían dos veces antes
de atacar a rusia sabiendo que ya la
federación tiene este misil dentro de
sus almacenes militares
rápidamente el zar mata zarmat el zar
mata por este pueblo euroasiático hindú
iraní de tiempos de trabajando y de los
romanos pues este misil es sucesor del
ss guión 18 alias satán que la otan así
le llamaba con esa numeración vojvoda
era el nombre que la unión soviética
lidad vale ese ese guión 18 y este era
un misil balístico intercontinental
pasado en tierra pesado que podía llevar
pues más de 10 unos viejos y más pesadas
de 750 kilotones cada una si le añades
250 kilos de sal de sao viva ya tienes
un megatón como decir un millón de
toneladas de tnt
y podría ir también con ayudas con
contramedidas como decir señuelos para
engañar a las defensas antimisiles y
halagos y bajeza a las diez entonces el
nuevo es para reemplazar al ese siguió
18 que por cierto era fábrica de 'news
más que es un gran conglomerado de
fabricación también de los cohetes
espaciales que están ucrania otro motivo
quizá putin querer quedarse con ucrania
por sus minerales su agricultura y
también su sector es
importante entonces doctor estaría
basado porque nos quedan pocos minutos
para terminar el programa tengo que
hacer el lamento tenerlo que cortar pero
tengo que abordar otros temas
importantes y se extiende mucho está en
sus respuestas quiero preguntarle a la
doctora boina sobre la situación que
está viviendo polonia al recibir a
millones de ucranianos ya esta semana
superaron los cinco millones de
emigrantes ucranianos que han viajado a
lo largo y ancho del continente europeo
a través de las fronteras de polonia
eslovaquia hungría rumanía moldavia
incluso ya muchos han comenzado a llegar
también a américa incluso a eeuu y
canadá
usted debe conocer un poco más de la
situación en polonia de lo que se está
viviendo allí que tanto esfuerzo tiene
que hacer el gobierno polaco para llevar
a cabo este operativo para recibir a los
migrantes y que tanto va a poder
soportar
el sistema de bienestar polaco y el
estado polaco para recibir a todas estas
personas
la situación es obviamente muy compleja
muy complicada porque efectivamente
durante esos 60 días casi 60 días que
han durado la guerra han llegado a
polonia 2 millones 800 mil refugiados o
sea en los últimos días están llegando
más o menos 20.000 personas diario pero
ha habido momentos en no hace mucho hace
pocas semanas cuando 100 10 200.000
personas cruzaban la frontera de polonia
en diferentes puntos en diferentes
cruces la verdad es que en ese sentido
hay que decir que el gobierno polaco
está muy comprometido con la causa
ucraniana y ha puesto mucho esfuerzo
precisamente para preparar una
infraestructura para atender a los
refugiados por una parte y por otra
parte también hay una solidaridad de la
sociedad polaca que hay familias muchas
familias polacas muchos polacos muchas
polacas que ofrecen incluso sus casas a
casa sus departamentos para que los
ucranianos puedan
y pasar ese tiempo digamos de refugio en
el territorio de polonia esos refugiados
que llegan al extranjero que salen de
ucrania y llegan a los países como
polonia son principalmente mujeres y
niños niñas o sea básicamente pues los
grupos en ese sentido más vulnerables
lic y a eso también ha habido que
ajustar obviamente toda la
infraestructura y todas las necesidades
hoy en día en las escuelas polacas más
de 200 mil niños ucranianos ya están
estudiando ya está en la primaria en la
secundaria y en ese sentido yo diría si
hay un ajuste y una disposición muy
grande de los polacos para ayudar por
otra parte hay otro factor yo creo que
relevante en polonia ya ha habido
ucranianos que han vivido en el país
antes de la guerra
ucranianos viviendo en polonia esa
población también ha expresado ha salido
con obviamente las manos abiertas y ha
ayudado muchísimo a los refugiados ahora
bien las necesidades son gigantescas y
en ese sentido aparte del presupuesto
que destina el gobierno polaco también
obviamente hay ayuda nacional de
diferentes organizaciones
internacionales sobre todo las naciones
unidas pero también cruz roja y hablar
desde eso los países como eeuu también
diferentes países y las instituciones de
la unión europea como comisión europea
han destinado fondos especialmente para
pues atender las necesidades de los
refugiados doctora boina me quedan ya
solamente un par de minutos para
finalizar el programa quiero hacer las
conclusiones quiero comenzar con usted
sobre lo que va a suceder en este
conflicto para las próximas semanas
siempre lo digo no tenemos bola de
cristal para saber el futuro y día a día
este conflicto toma un rumbo diferente y
cada día moscú a kiev a bruselas
sorprende con alguna acción a medida que
toman dentro de este conflicto que
piensa usted que puede suceder en los
próximos días se retira el ejército
ucraniano rusia tomará más fuerza
celebrarán los rusos el día de la
victoria con la caída de mariupol como
lo ve usted
mira yo creo que rusia está perdiendo
esa guerra no cabe ninguna duda no ha
logrado sus principales objetivos
entonces tiene que contentarse con lo
que realmente puede hacer tomando en
consideración pues las capacidades de
sus fuerzas armadas y eso significa
concentrarse en la ocupación de la parte
sur y parte oriental de ucrania para
transformar esos territorios en los
territorios repúblicas independientes y
probablemente en un futuro cercano
incorporarlas a la federación rusa ahora
bien va a ser un proceso sobre todo
cuando hablamos de ucrania oriental de
nunca es donde eso sea de la parte esa
lucas donde extiende la parte de saque
que repúblicas autoproclamarse así es
exactamente pues eso va a va a ocupar a
rusia pues yo diría bastante tiempo
pueden ser semanas pueden ser meses y en
ese tiempo vamos a ver más acciones que
pasó extenderse también al sector
energético y vamos a ver si número gol
más problemas también desde ese punto de
vista pues más global muchos temas para
analizar doctora boina doctors al día se
me acaba tiempo les quiero agradecer por
haber estado con nosotros aquí en el
debate de france 24 muchas gracias por
haber compartido sus puntos de vista en
torno a estos diferentes temas
relacionados con la guerra en ucrania
ustedes sigan con france24 tenemos más
información para ustedes
[Música]